6041 the title of it is discrete-time
signal processing you put in a signal
with a certain frequency content my
teaching style has always been very
highly interactive first basically I
need feedback from the class as to how
they're relating to the material one of
the things I came across was clickers
problem gets put up I asked the students
to think about it for no more than a
minute or two minutes and they would
post their answer then a histogram would
be displayed so that's instantaneous
feedback to me and to them and it's all
anonymous
they loved the in-class questions they
thought there was a tremendous
enhancement of the teaching utilizing
the MIT X platform all of those
exercises would then go live on the MIT
X site and they would get feedback as to
whether they were getting it correct or
not the homework problems were all
online they liked the fact that when
they were working the problem sets they
could get immediate feedback as to
whether their answer was correct or not
we augmented the platform to put in text
boxes in which they could put their
explanation a lot of these things
absolutely would enhance everyone's
teacher the effort to incorporate them
requires a commitment
they take effort and they take resources
and they take funding so you have this
sort of complicated thing where you're
taking the influence this experience
this semester has radically changed the
way I think about teaching I am now a
strong believer of the concept of the
flipped classroom